it's true you just had a baby yes
congratulations
wait you had a baby six weeks ago Lord a
baby boy okay what did you name him
Rex Rex yes okay ten days to come up
with that little name I didn't name my
baby for ten days you didn't even for
ten days that's kind of a long time I've
heard of people taking four five six to
ten days is a long time what was a time
and then I gave my baby the name that I
didn't realize is very similar to my
dog's name
yeah Rep Chizik Asterix no my dog is
actually called Astro a strict so we
often call the baby Asterix baby papi
are you good at because it takes a while
to adjust to the craziness of being a
parent huh
especially when your newborn shows up
it's total panic I mean and no one
explains anything that's what I was
prepared for this no one's prepared I
was in fact I was so disorganized during
my pregnancy I had a friend I was like
you've got to do a prenatal class and
just you have no idea what you're
getting yourself into and the forms came
through and I was filling them out and
it said how did you hear about us and
and it said mother's name mother's
occupation' partner's name I said to my
partner what is so weird that they've
asked for the mother's name first what
and this went on and he was looking mean
he went you're the mother
I thought they wanted my mother's I'm a
motto yeah okay Lucy it sounds like you
get confused a lot
a few times just yeah can you do the can
you do the you go to the diapering yet
that is the thing it's amazing it starts
out like ah and then very quickly very
speedy especially because you in the
middle of the night but we didn't it
took a long time to figure out that um
on the on the diaper there's the little
stripe that changes color when the baby
has ready to have his diaper changed and
my boyfriend came up with this idea was
like only you know it changed color well
I thought we were gonna be millionaires
tonight someone pointed out that
actually know that that stripes changing
previously I was sticking my finger and
going kind of person are you okay
well that I've done other babies you
know that they're gonna have a digital
diaper soon it's like I have poop you
know it's gonna be something it speaks
to you a little cheer or something would
be nice a to you could put it could put
your you could put your favorite songs
download them on the diaper oh the kid
alright we gotta change it that out
number two that's yeah